Gut.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Somaz.
Ich bin hier als Assistenz-Arztin.
Ich würde mich mit Ihnen gerne das Anamnesgeschichte führen.
Vor diesem Gespräch möchte ich ein paar Personen hier fragen.
Ist das für Sie in Ordnung?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Gisela Brokman.
Gisela Brokman.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja.
Gisela mit G.
S-E-L-A.
Gisela.
Ja.
Und der Nachname Brokman B-R-O-C-K-M-A-N-N.
Mit 2 N.
Ja.
Okay.
Frau Brokman, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 68 Jahre.
68 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18.
März 1953.
1953.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,66 m.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
67 kg.
Frau Brokman, spreche ich Ihren Namen richtig aus?
Brokman, das ist richtig.
Brokman, ja.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe so seit, na, ich gucke auf die Uhr seit circa 4 Stunden,
habe ich sehr starke Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe sehr starke Kopfschmerzen.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, die kamen schon ziemlich plötzlich,
aber sie wurden jetzt im Laufe der letzten Stunden immer stärker.
Stärken.
Und sind die Schmerzen immer da oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nein, die sind eigentlich immer da.
Das drückt so, als ob man etwas aus dem Kopf raus will.
Ja, okay.
Und wo tut es am starksten weg?
Na, so im Hinterkopf hier hinten, aber auch bis vorne hin.
Also ist eigentlich überall im Kopf.
Überein, beidseitig.
Ja.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Druckschmerzen haben.
Könnten Sie mehr beschreiben, diese Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe den Eindruck nicht, dass es von außen drückt so,
sondern dass es raus will aus dem Kopf.
Raus will, ja.
Raus.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzschmelle von 1 bis 10?
Da würde ich schon sagen 9 bis 10.
9 bis 10, aber das klingt sehr stark.
Ja.
Solche Ihnen Schmerzmittel geben oder halten Sie?
Ich habe schon Schmerzmittel genommen.
Zuerst eine Paracetamol.
Ja.
Und danach noch mal eine Ibuprofen 400, aber es hat nichts geholfen.
Nicht geholfen.
Ja, okay.
Und ich zeige dir Schmerz in andere Körperteile aus.
Nee, so ein bisschen hier hinten in den Nacken,
hinter Kopf so ein bisschen, aber nee, woanders hin nicht.
Nee.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie auch Nackenstaff gehabt?
Ja, es tut mir so weh.
Ich kann es nicht gut bewegen, aber so richtig Nackenstaff nicht.
Ich möchte den Kopf gar nicht gut bewegen,
weil es dann man hat fürchte ich, dass es noch mehr wird.
Ja, okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen außer Bewegung?
Ich bin vielleicht jetzt letzten Minuten höre ich hier,
das ist ziemlich laut gewesen, als ich hier hervor sehr lärm empfindlich.
Ja, okay.
Aber ich kann auch, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe,
auch nicht so richtig schauen, ich sehe etwas verschwommen.
Ja, sie verschwommen.
Ja, ja.
Ja, Flimmer, sind denn Augenflimmern oder so?
Nee, Flimmer nicht so sehr, aber es ist nicht so klar.
Es ist so wie wenn ich etwas durch eine schlechte Scheibe sehe,
durch eine dreckige Scheibe.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Schön, ich habe mich sonst bis vorhin sehr wohl gefühlt,
aber wie gesagt, vor vier Stunden begann diese Kopfschmerzen.
Haben Sie auch früher ein Nichebeschwerden gehabt?
Ja, ich habe mal Kopfschmerzen, aber das ist selten.
Ich nehme auch ganz selten eine Schmerz-Tablette sonst.
Das kenne ich so nicht, diese Kopfschmerzen kenne ich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie auch schon das Bewusstsein verloren?
Nee, aber mir ist ziemlich schwindelig und mir ist auch übel,
und ich habe auch dreimal erbrochen.
Dreimal erbrochen.
Wie sieht das Erbrochen aus?
Das war so schleimig, etwas grünlich, aber nicht auffällig.
Nicht dunkel, auch kein Blut oder so.
Okay.
Wird Ihnen ein Schwert für den Albin?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich sehe eher so alles verschwungen,
als ob ich irgendwie durch ein dreckiges, schmutziges Glas schaue.
Ich muss nicht genau, ich kann Sie nicht so scharf sehen.
Okay.
Sind Ihnen auch Krippelgefür oder irgendwelche Lähmungen
oder Taupajtsgefür aufgefallen?
Nee, aber wie gesagt, mir ist schwindelig.
Ich möchte mich nicht groß bewegen, ich bleibe lieber sitzen.
Ja, immer sitzen.
Haben Sie auch Brustchmarts?
Nee.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Bekommen Sie Atemnot?
Nee.
Haben Sie Probleme auf dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlass?
Nein, das war bisher alles in Ordnung.
Da war ich auch schon zu einer Vorsorge,
Untersuchung zu einer Darmspiegelung vor zwei Jahren.
Alles gut.
Alles gut, ja.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe seit einigen Jahren, 10 Jahren,
habe ich hohen Blutdruck.
Haben Sie Regalmäßig Iran Blutdruck gemessen?
Ja, ich habe es heute nicht gemessen.
Aber ich nehme dafür auch Medikamente ein.
Was ist die Medikamente?
Ich habe einen Zettel mit, da steht drauf,
Visoprolol,
wie viel Milligramm?
Da steht 5.
Davon nehme ich morgens eine und abends eine.
Ja.
Und dann steht hier noch Ramiebriel 5.
Auch morgens eine.
Das kann ich nicht gut lesen.
Da steht drauf, Hydrochlorotheazit.
Hydrochlorotheazit, ja, wie viel Milligramm?
25, morgens eine.
Okay.
Ist Ihre Hypertonie mit Medikamentus gut eingestellt?
Wissen Sie?
Ja.
Ich habe eine andere Erkrankung.
Ich hab eine andere Unterstand.
Ich gehe so ein bis zweimal im Jahr zum Hausarzt.
Der misst den Blutdruck.
Und der sagt es mir das letzte Mal.
Ah, der ist ein bisschen hoch.
Ja.
Ich sollte jetzt wieder zur Kontrolle kommen.
Aber das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich messe nicht gerne selber den Blutdruck.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Ja, ich muss häufiger zum Augenarzt. Der Augenarzt sagt, ich hätte einen grünen Starr.
Dann nehme ich zweimal am Tag Tropfen. Aber die habe ich jetzt nicht mit. Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Okay, kein Problem. Seit wann haben Sie Grünarztar?
Ja, das ist noch nicht so lange. Vielleicht fünf Jahre.
Okay. Hatten Sie noch andere Erklankungen?
Nein, ich fühle mich sonst eigentlich ganz gut.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mal blind am Operation gehabt. Kann ich Ihnen aber nicht genau sagen, wann.
Und ich hatte eine geilen Operation wegen Kallensteinen. Das war vor sechs Jahren.
Sind diese beiden Operationen Komplikationen ausverlaufen?
Ja, war alles gut.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Lebensgewahrheit gewünscht halten wissen.
Brauchen Sie Frau Robsmann?
Nein, ich habe noch nie gewaucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so einmal in der Woche, da treffe ich mich mit einer Nachbarin abends.
Da trinken wir mal Einglaswein, aber mehr nicht. Das ist nicht viel.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage. Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein.
Drogen kenne ich nicht.
Frau Robsmann, haben Sie Allergie und Sartregulierkeiten?
Ich habe bisher immer alles vertragen. Ich kann alles essen.
Die Medikamente, die ich bisher bekommen habe, habe ich auch vertragen.
War gut.
Nein, nein, alles gut.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Meine Eltern leben beide nicht mehr.
Der Vater ist gestorben, da war er 75.
Da hatte er einen Schlaganfall.
Die Mutter ist gestorben nach einem Sturz zu Hause.
Da hatte sie einen Oberschenkelbruch.
Anschließend ist eine Lungenentzündung gestorben.
Da war sie 80.
Entzündung oder Lungenembole?
Entzündung war das.
Mein Mann ist verstorben vor drei Jahren.
Der hatte auch einen Schlaganfall.
Tut mir leid, Frau Robsmann.
Das war für Sie sehr schwierige Zeit.
Ja.
Kommen Sie darauf?
Gut.
Ich habe Sie nicht verstanden.
Kommen Sie recht darauf?
Ja.
Ich wohne alleine, aber ich bin recht.
Ich habe nette Nachbarn und nette Freunde.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Die leben hier in der Stadt.
Wir haben guten Kontakt.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt.
Ich bin seit zwei Jahren in Rente.
Ich habe früher im Büro gearbeitet.
Als Bürokraft.
Sehr gut.
Frau Robsmann, ich habe alle wichtigste Informationen bekommen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Oder gibt es etwas, das Sie mir sagen möchten?
Was glauben Sie, was das sein kann?
Dieser starke Kopfschmerz.
Wie lange halte ich das nicht mal aus?
Die anamnistische Angabe,
am Ehestrand auch Schlag-Ampfeil hin.
Aber das ist dafür.
Für die etwas richtig zu sagen.
Ich brauche noch Untersuchungen.
Und noch einige weitere Prozedure.
Ich habe noch eine Prozedur.
Ich werde Sie über weitere Schritte informieren.
Gut.
Danke.
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Und warten Sie im Untersuchungraum.
Oder im Untersuchungsraum.
Ich mache es.
Sie machen jetzt eine Zusammenarbeit.
Ich habe eine Zusammenarbeit mit einer anderen.
Sie machen jetzt eine Zusammenfassung für sich.
5 Minuten.
Dann sehen wir uns gleich.
Hallo, Herr Abaratz.
Ich habe gerade eine Neupatientin aufgenommen.
Haben Sie Zeit für dies?
Es handelt sich um Frau Gisela Brogsmann.
Sie ist die Frau von der
1868 Jahre alt.
Am 18.3.943.
Sie ist 50 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 60 kg schwer.
Und 1 Meter 88.
16.
Frau Brogsmann.
Sie stellte sich heute bei uns heute.
Sie stellte sich zur 5.
CHAEP,
Sie beschreibt als Schmerz in Duruk, Duruk und Raus gehen.
Diese Schmerzen seien ganz im Kopf lokalisiert und dagegen nehmen sie Paracetamol und Ubu-Prüfen.
Aber sie haben keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Okay.
Und die Patientin klagt überall,
Visusverlust, Gleichgewicht, Störungen, Vartigo, Nausea und dreimal MSS.
Ja.
Anschließend beschreibt, sie
die Intensität der Schmerzen aus Non-Bisten.
Diese Schmerzen seien sehr stark.
Ja.
Und sie haben nie bevor ähnliche Schmerzen gehabt.
Hat die Patientin eine Vorgeschichte?
Hat sie Risikofaktoren?
Ja.
Bei der Patientin sei arterialer Hepatione seit 10 Jahren und Glukon bekannt.
Und noch weitere Risikofaktoren ist ihre alte, 68 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Und sie sei als Kind appendoktomiert und vor sechs Jahren kolischistektomiert.
Okay.
Die sind verratzt.
Ja.
Aber das ist jetzt, glaube ich, für die Akkudiagnose nicht so relevant.
Ja, ja, nicht relevant.
Ja.
Und hat die Patientin Bewusstheitsverluste gehabt schon?
Nein, Beelsteinverlust, Fieber, neurologische Beschwerden,
cardiologische Beschwerden wurden verneilt.
Okay.
Gibt es eine Trauma an am Nese?
Ist sie gestürzt in letzter Zeit?
Ja, ja, ich musste fragen, aber ich habe nicht gefangen.
Okay.
Okay, müssen wir noch klären.
Haben Sie bei der Patientin den Blutdruck gemessen?
Äh.
Ja, ich, ich, jetzt nicht, aber ich, ich, ich würde so Erdmonitor anschließen
und Blutdruck, Herzfrequenzeln sehen und wie schnell wie möglich eine EKG schreiben
und danach eine Strokeunit überweisen.
Ja, okay.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Apoplex.
Apoplex.
Hat sie außer den, dem, dem Visostörungen und dem Schwindel sonst neurologische Ausfälle?
Nein, keine.
Nee, kann es auch eine Hypertone Krise sein?
Ja, kann sein, ja.
Okay.
Meine Differenzialdiagnose auf die Hypertension, Hypertensikrise.
Kann es eine, kann es eine Subarachnoidalblutung sein?
Ja, sein.
Okay.
Kann das sein, ja.
Kann es ein akuter Glaukom-Anfall sein?
Ja, kann sein.
Ja.
Okay.
Damit hätten wir so die Differenzialdiagnosen befunden.
Ja.
Sie haben vorhin, ich finde, das haben Sie gut, gut berichtet.
Auch gut die, die Fachbegriffe benutzt, die medizinischen Fachbegriffe.
Ich finde es immer wichtig bei solchen Patienten mit solcher einer Akutsymptomatik.
Sie haben die Patientin gefragt, brauchen sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Ja, aber ich würde als erstes immer daran denken.
Ich glaube, das ist auch für die Prüfung wichtig, jetzt kurz zu sagen, Frau Brockmann,
ich messe Ihnen als erstes jetzt gerade den Blutdruck und schließe Sie in die Monitor an.
Dann kann man schon mal sehen, wie hoch ist der Blutdruck?
Ja.
Und im Monitor können Sie zumindest schon mal sagen, Herzrhythmus ist okay,
das gibt der Patientin auch eine gewisse Sicherheit.
Ja.
Aber wichtig ist als erstes, bei so etwas will ich immer den Blutdruck essen.
Es kann ja ein Ecypertone-Krise sein und dann müssen Sie eigentlich schon
in der Ambulanz bei der Anameseerhebung aktiv werden, indem Sie versuchen,
den Blutdruck moderat zu senken.
Ja.
Ja, ja, wichtig.
Man kann euch auch geben durch Biotensinen und was es da alles gibt an Präparaten,
sublingual, aber schonend dem Blutdruck senken.
Wenn Sie jetzt einen Blutdruck, sage ich mal, hätte von 230, 240 zu 120,
dann müssten Sie ja möglichst in der Ambulanz noch tätig werden und nicht
erst abwarten, bis Ihre Anameseerhebung zu Ende ist.
Dann sollten Sie gleich tätig werden.
Weil es dann auch ein Notfall und das andere beim Glaukom,
ja, muss man in Erwägung ziehen, ein Glaukom, Anfall, ein Akkuter,
der kann auch so die Fussekoptschmerzen machen,
zumindest in die Differenzialdiagnose mit Denken.
Apoplex kann natürlich auch sein.
Subarachnödalblutung bei der Vorgeschichte, Risikofaktor Hypertonie.
Aber wie gesagt, zuerst über Blutdruck messen.
Ja, ich würde im Praxis Blutdruck messen,
aber diese Prüfungssimulation ist immer so,
muss man 20 Minuten an Ambulanz erheben muss.
Vielleicht ist es so ganz kurz getan und zu sagen,
Frau Brockmann, während ich Sie in Fragen stelle,
messe ich Ihnen gerade Ihren Blutdruck und messe Ihren Sauerstoff
und hänge Sie an einem Monitor.
Das ist eine Sache, die dauert vielleicht eine Minute.
Ja, ja, das ist eine gute Zeit.
Dann haben Sie wichtige Informationen.
Ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig, wenn Sie so etwas dann dem Oberarzt präsentieren,
dass der Oberarzt auch sieht.
Ha, es ist das Wesentliche schon mal gemacht worden,
um jetzt nicht zu schauen.
Wenn der Blutdruck normal ist, gut, dann kann ich jetzt erst mal sagen,
habe ich jetzt erst mal Zeit, ich brauche jetzt noch nichts zu machen vielleicht.
Aber wenn der Blutdruck viel zu hoch ist, dann würde ich schon gleich
etwas unternehmen und zwar keine Schmerzmittel geben,
sondern eben versuchen, den Blutdruck etwas schonend zu senken.
Es geht jetzt ja nicht darum, mit was Sie das machen.
Es ist jetzt keine Fachprüfung, sondern nur zu zeigen.
Ich mache jetzt kurze Akkutdiagnostik, um dann weiter tätig zu werden.
Aber die Umsteilung von der Anamese
in der Straße der Patienten und jetzt zum Oberarzt
mit dem medizinischen Fachbegriffen, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Ja, danke.
Und ich glaube, das ist ja auch in der Prüfung gewünscht und gefordert,
dass Sie das möglichst stressfrei für sich.
Ja, meine Prüfung ist Montag.
Und ja, klar.
Ja, also insofern finde ich,
versuchen Sie, in sich zu bleiben, ruhig zu kommen,
nicht zu lange Sätze zu machen, lieber den Satz dann beenden und
einen neuen Satz, weil das wird gerade in Deutsch oft in der Grammatik immer
schwieriger, wenn der Satz je länger erlernt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wo haben Sie die Prüfung?
Bei welcher Kammer?
Düsseldorf, in Düsseldorf.
Düsseldorf, ja.
Da war, glaube ich, vor einigen Wochen auch schon jemand,
eine Kollegin aus Krefeld.
Ja, ja.
Ja, sie haben schon bestanden.
Bestanden, ja.
Oh, sehr gut.
Und Marve auch bestanden.
Ja, ja, sehr gut.
Ja, alles gut. Prima.
Ja, ich habe auch ein gutes Gefühl, dass Sie das gut hinkriegen.
Ja, danke.
Danke vielmals.
Ja, dann wünsche ich Ihnen viel Erfolg.
Und wenn es irgendwie noch fragt.